et vous allez entendre maintenant un
témoignage stupéfiants celui d'un ancien
policier de la bac nord de marseille il
dénonce une corruption parmi certains de
ses anciens collègues
sachez au préalable que ce policier a
été révoqué au cours de l'été mais qu
après les révélations faites au cours de
sa procédure disciplinaire le procureur
de la république a ouvert une
information judiciaire
le témoignage a été recueilli par l'ue
aubert et ludovic moreau marseille c'est
sylvie la cbi là où il existe une police
à part l'argent coule à flot dans les
cités et au lieu de s'occuper de faire
le boulot de flic ont fait le petit
boulot de riz poussière qu'on va
récupérer des jeunes dans les cités
quand des sacoches ou compte de l'argent
sur eux et puis on passe des petits dire
qu'on les laisse repartir on regarde on
garde l'argent pour pour soi on découvre
des scooters volés dans une dans une
cité où deux fonctionnaires ont besoin
de s'approcher de quad cross ou quoi on
prend vite le cam 1 2
police on l'amène à la maison et on le
garde pour soi vous avez rapporté tous
ces faits vous les avez démence et oui
effectivement on a eu des entretiens
avec un autre hiérarchie à plusieurs
reprises et à partir du moment où on a
dénoncé ces faits on a commencé à vivre
l'enfer dans la police marseillaise
c'est à dire qu'on était des hommes et
des femmes à abattre est-ce que vous
avez été menacée oui on a aussi des
manettes de menaces à domicile certaines
ont été obligés de déménager
on vous met au placard les flics comme
moi craignent pour leur sécurité
pour la famille ils sont capables de
tout pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
accepté de témoigner aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on accepter témoigner parce
que on en a ras-le-bol
on aimerait ça me travaille correctement
et ça c'est pas possible actuellement
qu'est ce qui vous empêche de faire
votre travail correctement déjà des
fonctionnaires de police qui sont ni
mauvais côté de la barrière qui nous
empêchent de travailler et notre
hiérarchie
notre hiérarchie t de leur côté quand
vous dénoncez décès de confiance sauf
que vous dénoncez des collègues qui
frappe des jeunes à tout va pour rien
quand vous dénoncez des collègues qui
volent d'autres gens dans les cités et
qu'on vous dit que si vous n'êtes pas
content vous quittez votre service on a
l'impression de marcher sur la tête donc
ces policiers la agissons totale
impunité tout à fait tout à fait parce
que alors s'est il est toujours plus
simple de se taire de réunir le policier
qu'à une famille mais il n'a pas envie
de il n'a pas envie de souffrir il a pas
envie de perdre on travaille donc
fatalement des caisses qui fait baisse
les yeux et il fait ses huit heures de
boulot et puis s'en va il préfère police
a demandé une enquête à l'igpn mais n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer en raison de la
procédure en cours
[Musique]